we're running very short on time now
Darla dewald is from grassfire nation
and is the national director of resist
net.com please welcome
Darla hey
everybody well God bless
America my time is limited so if you
will just bear with me I want to go
through my speech I've written it out
because I don't want to miss any
anything okay thank you 911 will forever
live in infamy the grief associated with
this date will lay heavy on the hearts
and minds of the survivors victims
families and all Americans for all time
the ground affected by this tragedy is
seen by many as sacred a symbol of evil
injustices yet at the heart of this area
is faith hope and
love to s boil this Faith and Hope as we
build a new upon this ground and honor
those who served and those who
sacrificed we do so with faith that God
will heal this land and the hearts and
souls of
America over the past few days I've had
the great honor of speaking with many
New York City business people
firefighters First Responders and
residents they've experienced the long
long journey of recovery since 911 2001
these individuals have expressed their
angst and emotional recounting of this
journey and I completely understand
their opposition to this
mosque I've listened to the
spokespersons with the mosque state that
this mosque Islamic Cultural Center
would be instrumental in building a
bridge to serve and improve
relationships I've also listened as the
majority of Americans in New York and
the rest of this country have expressed
their
opposition to The Chosen location due to
the reminder of the great suffering we
have incurred at the hands of Islamic
terrorists yesterday grassfire Nation
delivered 10
14,622 petitions to Mayor Bloomberg's
office representing
Americans who stand in Stern
opposition We Believe to build at Ground
Zero would in fact show Less in the way
of peace and tolerance but more in lack
of respect and a bold Act of
insensitivity although the Constitution
affords this right we do not believe
that this is as much about rights as it
is about honor and
integrity in other words just because
you can do something doesn't mean you
should as a predominantly Christian
Nation As Americans who believe in the
foundations of our
Republic as a nation reflective on what
will forever be a tragic reminder we ask
for your charity today we ask you to
consider reconsider the
location and to display true sensitivity
and respect as a peaceful religion you
claim to
be and we ask that you listen to the
hearts and angst of Americans who vant
oppose the mosque if your desire is
truly about repairing relationships and
building bridging a Great Divide moving
the mosque would be a major step toward
Good Will and peace with Americans thank
you God bless you